When buying a car, many people tend to put more energy into its color than any other thing.
Buyers should think about what they will use their car for.
They should ask: "How many people do I need to transport?",...
..."What kind of driving do I most often do?", "How long is my commute?",...
..."What kind of gas mileage do I need?" But they rarely do.
In too many cases,...
...people choose a car because it has an eye-catching style or it is a trendy favorite.
Car makers know that they can strongly influence sales...
...by selecting colors that appeal to the buyer's personality and self image.
Here's how color experts match your personality to the color of car you drive.
Silver: elegant, loves futuristic looks, cool.
White: fastidious.
Vibrant Red: sexy, speedy, high - energy and dynamic.
Light to Mid - blue: cool, calm, faithful, quiet.
Dark blue: credible, confident, dependable.
Taupe or light brown: timeless, basic and simple tastes.
Black: empowered, not easily manipulated, loves elegance, appreciates classics.
Neutral gray: sober, corporate, practical, pragmatic.
Dark green: traditional, trustworthy, well - balanced.
Bright yellow: trendy, whimsical, lively.
Yellow gold: intelligent, warm, loves comfort and will pay for it.
Sunshine yellow: sunny disposition, joyful and young at heart.
Deep brown: down-to-earth, no-nonsense.
Orange: fun - loving, talkative, fickle and trendy.
Deep purple: creative, individualistic, original.